[Music]
hello and allow me please to welcome you
to another episode of i' like to know my
name is CA Murray and it is our
privilege and pleasure to join with you
today at as we study the word of God and
answer those questions that you have
sent in to us uh I'm flanked by two
fellow Travelers on the road to glory
fellow students of the word to my left
is Pastor David Salazar pastor always
good to have you here uh and to study
the word of God with you amen Pastor
it's always a blessing to have you also
here with us and of course our founding
president Pastor Steven bore Pastor as
always good to study the word of God
with you all I can say is welcome
back we been away for just a little
while uh not on vacation doing the work
of the Lord and God has been been uh
blessing us uh and we thank him for that
gentlemen again it's always good to
study the word of God with both of you
as you are students of the word this is
I'd like to know it's a question and
answer program and if you want to be
part of the questions and the answers
then we encourage you in the strongest
possible terms to write us to email us
to call us just get the questions in and
we will answer them you can email us at
TV atoms
mv.org that is
tv.su tv.org and we will get to those
questions just as soon as we possibly
can the list is long and the line is is
quite long so we're answering them just
as fast as we can but this is what we
found gentlemen that if if we rush
through the questions and we don't
really do diligence to those who take
the time to write the questions in so
rather than speed we're kind of leaning
on the side of accur Y and thoroughness
so that you feel that your questions are
addressed seriously and that the answers
come from the word of God which is the
promise we make to you that always when
your questions come in if an answer can
be brought to you from the word of God
we will bring that answer to you that
promise we do make to you so Pastor
Salazar if you will pray for us we will
launch out and have a good time together
amen let's pray Heavenly Father we are
very delighted that we can come to you
at this hour to ask your Holy Spirit to
come into our midst to our minds to be
able to uh speak not according to your
own our own thoughts our own words but
we want to speak truth and we want you
to uh clear our mind so that we may
respond to the questions with thus said
the Lord I pray that you will be with us
now we pray this in Jesus name amen amen
and amen now according to you worthy
gentlemen I'm getting on board a train
that is already on the tracks and
already already moving M uh when last we
were together um a question comes in
from Kenya uh from Jude and I think you
had answered the first two of a
four-part question and we need now to
address questions three and four um he
writes in Hebrews chap 10: 5-7 there is
an interjection of this part a body thou
Hast prepared for me I'm not getting the
Rel reltionship of the phrase in
relationship to the rest of the verse so
I guess he wants a little explanation a
little exeresis on a body thou Hast
prepared for me so I want to turn to
that very quickly because a couple
things occur to me um if you read the
whole I guess you can call this an
interjection it's a u a little veering
off uh to something in particular but it
is very secate it makes sense when you
read the whole uh list of verses 5
through 7 because the the overall theme
is is sacrifice and of course much of
the book of Hebrews has to do with with
sacrifice with the fact that Christ is
I'll use the term the real deal and you
don't have to go to another that his
sacrifice was complete it was one time
and it was thorough and and this little
interjection deals with that when you
look at burnt offerings and sacrifices
of sin God has no pleasure in that so uh
something was arranged in heaven M so
that the continual sacrificial system
didn't have to be carried out one time
one sacrifice and that's what this body
being prepared is for to to complete
that work and that understanding
anything you gentlemen want to add yeah
I think when you connect verse
four with verse five and following it
becomes very clear as you were
mentioning uh speaking about the
sacrificial system in the Old Testament
it says for it is not possible that the
blood of bulls and goats could take away
sins so basically there's it's saying
that the old system was good because it
pointed forward to Christ right but it
did not deal definitively with
sin what did deal definitively with sin
well that's in the next verses yes says
therefore when he came into the world he
said sacrifice and offering you did not
desire in other words all those
sacrifices in the Old Testament that's
only functional uh sacrifice and
offering you did not desire but a body
have prepared for me a body to offer a
sacrifice the real sacrifice and then it
says in burnt offerings and sacrifices
for sin you had no pleasure then I said
behold I have come in the volume of the
book it is written on me to do your will
oh God uh so uh and then it says in
verse eight previously saying sacrifice
and offering burnt offerings and
offerings for sin you did not desire nor
had pleasure in them which are offered
according to the law then he said behold
I have come to do your will oh God he
takes away the first that's the
sacrificial system that he may establish
the second by that will we have been s
Sanctified through the offering of the
body there's the body that was prepared
for him the body of Jesus Christ once
for all yeah three times in this little
Soliloquy he says I'm not into
sacrifices I don't want sacrifices I
don't desire sacrifices so I had to
prepare Heaven had to prepare I use it
that way a an entity a being to come
down assume a body and make a sacrifice
that was once and for all and made it
done so he said it three times I'm just
not into sacrifices but sin has to be
dealt with and there's only one person
who could deal that would deal with that
and that's Jesus because the because the
blood of bulls and goats cannot take
away sin that's initiates the sequence
of the argument exactly exactly I I
believe that it's important to notice
that you know Christ shows also in these
um
he's actually speaking and Paul is
quoting uh Psalms 40: 6-8 and it shows
the the the the expression of of Jesus
showing his preexistence you know his
experience that he's coming to the Earth
to do the will of the father to be able
to receive the body the physical human
body to be able to experience the
sacrifice that he will make in
experation for sin so the only answer to
sin is not the sacrificial system that
that was only a shadow of Christ but it
was truly the uh the you know the
experience that Christ wanted to replace
with his own sacrifice he wanted to make
sure that as you mentioned you well
mentioned is his sacrifice is one and
for all you know there's one time done
so yeah the truth be told I think you
you touched on this uh Pastor bore the
that bulls and goats couldn't really do
anything it would those those things
were done in faith uh expecting the
sacrifice of Christ so it only had sense
given the fact that Christ was going to
come so you you you you did an act that
that foreshadowed the grand act and if
if the grand Act was never done those
bulls and goats would do nothing it's
just sort of a waste of time and also
important you know that God does did not
Delight in the sacrifices it was not
something that he found pleasure in
necessarily that it was a a system to
point to the need of an external Savior
for Mankind and this is really the you
know the ultimate sacrifice of Christ
coming as a as as a one of us to die for
us and save us yeah I think that word
you just tossed in is is very apropo an
external savior we don't have it in us
to save ourselves something has to
happen outside of us and even the acts
that we're doing just looks forward to
that day when that outside actor will
come in and save us from our pastor am
okay uh one more from Brother Jude help
me he says in question question for
differentiate between the old
Everlasting new and second
Covenant all right
um how many covenants are there let me
ask it that
way there's only one true Covenant there
you go the Everlasting there you go
there you go yes yeah there's only one
and that Covenant was between the father
and the son MH that if man should
sin uh the father would send Christ to
solve the problem of sin MH that's the
Everlasting Covenant Everlasting
Covenant and and El white explains the
reason why it's Everlasting is because
it existed long before sin came into the
universe yes there was an agreement
between the father and the son long
before uh anyone sinned and he going to
last forever because it really the
result of his that Everlasting Covenant
we are saved yeah the truth is the sin
experiment did not catch God by surprise
he had he had a mechanism to deal with
it uh and the problem with the Covenant
was not with the Covenant itself was the
fact that we broke it yes you know we we
were at fault so in in Jeremiah 31:31 we
all know this very very well uh I'm
trying to scan down here behold the days
are coming sayth the Lord that I will
make a New Covenant with the house of
Israel with the house of Judah not
according to the Covenant which I made
with with their fathers in the day that
I took them by the hand and led them out
of the land of Egypt my Covenant which
they broke um
though I was a husband to them says the
Lord uh but this is the Covenant that I
will make uh with the house of House of
Israel after those days sayeth the Lord
I will put my laws in their minds and
write it on their hearts so the
difference between the old Covenant and
the New Covenant is the writing material
and the material on which It Was Written
same Covenant but instead of being just
on a hard piece of stone now it's put in
the heart so it's the place that it's
written not the language of the Covenant
itself
yeah in the book of Hebrews the emphasis
in in the book of Hebrews uh we find in
the words good and better yes
particularly the word better the old
system was not
bad it the new system is better than the
old system cu the old system was still
Christ centered the old system pointed
forward to the Christ who was going to
come so it wasn't a bad system it was a
good system in that it pointed to Christ
MH the new system is better because the
new system actually um materializes what
was
promised before uhuh so the old Covenant
in the sense in the book of Hebrews is
the Covenant of the promise all the
ceremonies and all the sacrifices that
pointed forward to Christ the New
Covenant is the Fulfillment of what was
predicted in the ceremonial system MH is
it's the Fulfillment in Christ yes uh so
so basically there's an Everlasting
Covenant which Embraces all MH then
there's the old Covenant which is the
sacrificial system the New Covenant in
the sense that this is fulfilled in
Christ yes and the Everlasting Covenant
will exist in the future as you were
mentioning because the saved will review
The Plan of Salvation throughout the
ceaseless ages of Eternity so there's
only one Covenant only one Covenant
praise the Lord for that I think we need
to remember the context in which Hebrews
was written it was written to Hebrew
Christians who were thinking about
considering about considering rather
going back into Judaism they were
thinking about returning and so Hebrews
was written to let them know that going
back is not going to help you um Jesus
has done it once and for all and he is
complete and you are complete in him so
that that sort of ties and nice to what
you were saying because it's all about
Christ stay in Christ you don't you
don't win anything going back uh into
the old system your future is Jesus amen
and you've got to stay in in Jesus amen
yeah if anybody wants to pursue this
further uh I would recommend that they
read Hebrews chapter 7 and chapter 8 yes
where the idea of the two covenants is
developed uh and uh I think that if you
study those two chapters you should be
able to to explain uh you know what the
old and the new and the Eternal is uh if
I could just read one verse verse uh
verse
13 of chapter 8 it says in that he says
a New Covenant he has made the first
obsolete now what is becoming obsolete
and growing old is ready to vanish away
so when Jesus came all of the
prescriptions of the old Covenant were
made obsolete because that which they
pointed to was the Fulfillment was the
Fulfillment yeah that that is why in
verse 9 chapter 10 verse 99 we which we
actually used to answer the question
before uh it says that because of Christ
he takes away the first and he
established the second so the second is
that second Covenant but it's really um
as you mentioned Pastor B you know is on
better is a better you know promises is
a better uh than the one that was not
necessarily bad it was just not as good
as the second one because Christ
simplifies that one and you know you
have Matthew 26:28 where Jesus is
instituted the Lord's supper and he says
this is the blood of the New Covenant
which is shed for you well if there's a
new covenant there's an old one what is
the old one the blood of animals anim
correct the New Covenant is the blood of
Christ and one of the themes of the book
of Hebrews is better blood absolutely
yes the Old Testament blood was good
yeah but the blood of Jesus is better
amen prise Lord you know I I knew you
were going to hit I have three texts
from Matthew chapter 8 uh and 88:13 I
think sort of puts a pin in it and
really really pegs it really really
really well um it's it's an interesting
study it is one that will affirm you and
certainly affirm your love for Christ
and the sacrifice of Christ as being
Central uh to the whole Covenant theme
and theology so praise the Lord for for
that
amen all right is is Sandra the next one
or are we going to go back to this long
one I think it's Sandra it's Sandra okay
we'll go to to Sandra we don't don't
have a location uh again we encourage
you if you if you can if if it does not
stress you too much let us know when
you're writing from because it just lets
us know what the footprint of the
ministry is and um where uh we are
touching lives and and doing what we can
for the cause of Christ so sanra thank
you for writing question I have a
question regarding uh what the Bible
says about vegetarianism does the bible
say that we must be vegetarians uh in
preparing for the second coming of
Christ H well well this is an
interesting question and uh I can say
that the Bible does not necessarily
dictate that somebody needs to be
vegetarian to be saved you know there's
not such a that said the Lord you have
to be vegetarian uh but God has given us
very clear evidence in the Bible as far
as that he is interested in our physical
mental and spiritual health and with
that said he had given from
Genesis 1 verse 29 he establishes there
what his plan was for mankind what type
of food we should have when we were made
created it says there and God said
behold I have given you every Earth
bearing seed which is upon the face of
all the Earth and every tree in which it
there is fruit for of a tree yielding
seed to you it shall be for food or for
meat so in the very very beginning God
established that the ideal for mankind
what he wanted what he intended for us
to eat was to be a
vegetarian uh diet that was his plan now
as Sin came into the world and it was
not after but after the flood when
change things changed that God gave the
opportunity for mankind to partake of
eating meat which was again specific
only certain animals were to be eaten
not you know not every animal that moves
or anything that moves you know it was
only specifically the clean animals that
he established there and that's before
he even comes into the scene with Moses
and the levitical laws so there is
actually a clean clean and unclean
animals before he even declared them to
the you know Israelites and so um what
we can know from from this experience
you know God now is intend intending us
to return to the original plan
and I believe that we can see in the
scriptures that his intent is for us to
be healthier to for us to enjoy life to
have a strong body and a strong mind and
taking care of body means looking with a
very honest Approach at what is best for
my health and there is enough evidence
now that uh points that uh you know a
plan-based diet is a much healthier
approach there are many documentaries
made by you know people that are just
interested in in finding what's best for
human consumption that point to the fact
that it's always healthier and better
for humans to eat uh a a plant-based
diet or a vegetarian diet uh God has
said it from the beginning that was his
intention and I think that we need to
you know listen to that voice and of
course prophecy does point to the fact
that we should be abstaining today from
eating animal products as much as
possible uh you know Leviticus
3:17 gives some additional prescriptions
about the the animals that you can eat
it says there that you should not eat
any fat oh yes and you should not eat
anything with blood so even though God
allowed partaking of clean
Meats still they could not eat the fat
and they could not eat the blood M
bottom line is there will not be a
McDonald's in the New Jerusalem
mhm or killing of any animal or no there
will be no death there we will not be
killing animals we will not be eating
bacon Etc because God is going to return
us to the original diet that he
established in the Garden of Eden which
you read in Genesis 1 129 the Bible also
says that the animals will be
vegetarians can you imagine a vegetarian
lion well the Bible says that the
animals originally were vegetarians
that's in Genesis
1:30 the same is going to be true at the
end of time when we go to heaven so uh
you know is God going to change our
tastes on the way to heaven I do believe
no we've learned to educate our taste
here on Earth and uh you know God is not
going to change our character he's not
going to change our tastes he's going to
change our
body uh into an immortal Incorruptible
body but he's not going to to change our
tastes so it's best to follow God's
original plan you know people are
following Plan B well not Sabbath but
Sunday oh not two genders but a hundred
you know uh not really marriage between
a man and a woman but but between a man
and a man and uh you know not
distinctive roles in in marriage and in
the church you know any everybody has
the same role so man has turned upside
down everything that got established and
God's plan is that we go back to the
beginning his plan in the beginning is
the best plan because it gives us joy
gives us happiness it makes us healthier
and it makes us have a better mood
because what we eat has a lot to do with
our mood yes indeed you know it's
interesting um man because mankind
settles for near perfect we tend to
think God is satisfied with near perfect
but we see in studying the Bible that
God is very precise he's precise about
the day he's precise about the diet he's
precise about the beginning end of the
Sabbath he doesn't take near he wants he
wants perfection in our following of him
amen um and we see that with with with
with diet um when we came out of the arc
as you mentioned there were seven of one
kind and two of another why there seven
because you got to eat some so you got
to leave some well the unclean ones two
because you didn't e anymore you're not
going to touch them so leave them alone
uh so God made that differentiation long
before si uh and the PE and the people
knew it God wants the best for us not
nearly perfect uh he wants he wants you
to do the best to eat the best live the
best clean clean water clean air do the
best you can uh give him your best then
of course we can expect the best from
him and the reason why Ellen White
recommends that we totally discard even
clean
Meats is because circumstances have
changed yeah anal you know back in
biblical times they didn't have all
these hormones that they injected in the
animals the animal world was not as
diseased as it is today and so to what
God allowed in the past he says it's not
safe now so God changes his counsel when
circumstances changes change to be in
harmony with himself with his own will
you know I say some sometimes I say to
people uh you know uh does God say well
you know I allowed you to eat meat in
the past does it man matter if it's
diseased and if it's full of hormones I
said you could eat it once and so you
can eat it now no when circumstances
change God changes his counsel and God
has given counsel through the spirit of
Prophecy that meat is no longer safe not
even clean meats are safe anymore so
they should be discarded in this period
of History yes and to add that Pastor
you know there's also another aspect
that we have to be mindful in the
specifically about meat you know animal
processing for that it's really a cruel
experience a cruel thing that's
happening with animals too I mean the
the industry for meat is not necessarily
as it used to be before it's it's really
abusing animals like you said injecting
them with hormones so they can grow fast
and they grow in ways that are really
inhumane in many ways and so that's not
the ideal of the Lord and if we promote
that type of Lifestyle we eat those
things we know we are part of the
problem and I think that there's enough
evidence that we are better by
abstaining from meat even now as we are
seeing around the world you know white
says what was once safe isn't safe
anymore so don't partake of it correct
you know and besides that the
environment is contaminated animals eat
uh GMO food you know and uh you know it
just isn't safe anymore it isn't safe
anymore and you can do a quick study
look at the the first 10 Pacar anti-
deluvian and ones After the flood uh the
lifespan was cut very very short so even
in the clean days when the animals were
much cleaner than they are now it was
not good for for for your health well
we've come to an end of a program so
very very quickly our time is fast
slipping into eternity thank you so much
for writing thank you for so much for
contacting us we ask God's richest
blessing on you and keep watching keep
writing and we'll do the best we can to
answer God bless you we'll be back soon
[Music]